let's see if we can name this molecule
using the sometimes called the rs system
or the khan in gold pre-log system and
the first thing to do is just to see if
there are any chiral centers in this
molecule if there aren't then we don't
even have to use the rs system we could
just use our standard nomenclature rules
and we'd be done so if we look here this
carbon is attached to three hydrogens so
it's definitely not attracted to four
different groups same thing about this
carbon right here this carbon right here
is attached to a fluorine but then
attached to two you could view them as
two methyl groups so it's the same group
so this is also not a chiral carbon or
an asymmetric carbon
this carbon right here is attached to
a hydrogen and three other carbons but
each of these three carbons look like
different groups this carbon is attached
to two methyls in a fluorine this carbon
is attached to two hydrogens and a
bromine this carbon is just a methyl
group so this right here does look like
a chiral center it does look like a
chiral carbon and the other ones don't
this is just a methyl group has three
hydrogens so definitely not
attached to four different groups and
this is attached to two hydrogens and
those are obviously the same group so
this is also not a chiral center so we
have one chiral center so the rs naming
system will apply but a good starting
point we'll just to be naming it using
our standard nomenclature rules and to
do that we look for the longest carbon
chain here
and let's see we have if we start over
here and i don't know what direction i'm
going to name it from yet but i just
want to divide the identify the longest
chain if we went from here we have one
two three we could either go to four or
four there so we definitely have four
carbons
four carbon longest chain
longest chain
so that tells us that we will be using
the prefix but or it will be a butane
because there are all single bonds here
so it is a butane but to decide whether
we branch off it doesn't matter whether
we use this met this ch3 or the ch3
they're the same group but decide
whether we we break we use this as part
of the longest chain or we use that we
think about the rule that the longest
the the chain the core chain to use
should have as many simple groups
attached to it as possible as a few as
opposed to as few complex groups so if
we used if we used this carbon as part
of our longest chain then this will be a
group that's attached to it which would
be kind of a what is this a bromo
methyl group which is not as simple as
maybe it could be but if we use this
carbon in our longest chain we'll have
two groups we'll have a bromo attached
and we'll also have a methyl group and
that's what we want we want more simple
groups attached to the longest chain so
we're going to do is we're going to use
this carbon
this carbon this carbon and that carbon
as our longest chain and we want to
start from the end that has the it's
closest to something being attached to
it and that bromine is right there so
this is going to be our number one
carbon our number two carbon our number
three carbon and our number four carbon
and then we can label the different
groups and then figure out what order
they should be listed in
so this will be a so this is a one bromo
one bromo and then this will be a two
methyl right here two
to methyl and then let's see it's just a
hydrogen then three we have a fluoro so
on carbon 3 we have a fluoro
fluoro and then on carbon 3 we also have
a methyl group right here so we also
have a three
methyl
so when we name it we put in
alphabetical order bromo comes first so
this thing right here is
one
bromo
one bromo and then alphabetically fluoro
comes first and it comes next one bromo
3
fluoro
3 fluoro we have 2 methyls so it's going
to be 2 comma 3
dimethyl
di and remember the d doesn't count in
alphabetical order
dimethyl
dimethyl
dimethyl butane because we have the
longest chain is four carbons dimethyl
butane
so that's just the standard nomenclature
rules we still haven't used the rs
system now we can do that now to think
about that we already said that this is
our chiral center so we just have to
essentially rank the groups attached to
it in order of atomic number and then
use the the con in gold prelog rules and
we'll do all of that in this example so
let's look at the different groups
attached to it
so when you look at it this guy has
three carbons and a hydrogen carbon is
definitely higher in atomic number on
the periodic table has atomic number of
six hydrogens one and you probably know
that already so hydrogen is definitely
going to be number four so let me put
number four there next to the hydrogen
so hydrogen and we find a nice color to
do it i'll do it in white so hydrogen is
definitely the number four group but we
have to differentiate between this
carbon group that carbon group and that
carbon group and the way you do it if
there's a tie on the three carbons you
then look at what is attached to those
carbons and you compare the highest
thing attached to each of those carbons
to the highest things attached to the
other carbons and then you do the same
ranking so the highest and if and if
that's a tie then you keep going on and
on and on so on this carbon right here
we have a bromine
bromine has an atomic number
bromine has atomic number of 35 which is
higher than fluorine or which is higher
than carbon
so this guy has a bromine attached to it
this guy only has this guy only has
hydrogens attached to it this guy has a
fluorine attached to it that's the
highest thing so this is going to be the
the third lowest or i should say the
second to lowest because it only has
hydrogens attached to it so that is
number three the one that has a bromine
attached to it is going to be number one
is going to be number one and the one
that has a fluorine attached to it is
number two so this is the number two
group and just as a reminder we were
tied with the carbon so we had to look
at the next highest constituent and even
if this had
three fluorines attached to it the
bromine would still trump it you compare
the highest to the highest so now that
we've done that let me redraw this
molecule so it's a little bit easier to
visualize so i'll draw our chiral carbon
in the middle so let's draw our chiral
carbon
and i'm just doing this for
visualization purposes and right here we
have our number one group i'll literally
just call that our number one group so
right there
that is our number one group it's in the
plane of the screen so i'll just call
that our
number one group
that's our number one group
over here also in the plane of the
screen i have our number two group
that is our number two group so let me
do it like that
so then you have your number two group
number
two
just like that and then you have your
number 3 group behind the molecule right
now the way it's drawn we do that in
well maybe i'll do that in magenta so
then you have your number 3 group it's
behind the molecule so i'll do it like
this
this is our number three group
number three group and then we have our
number four group which is the hydrogen
pointing out right now and i'll just do
that in the yellow
we have our number four group pointing
out in front right now
so that is
number four
number four just like that and actually
maybe this one actually let me draw it a
little bit clearer so it looks a little
bit more like the tripod structure that
it's supposed to be so let me redraw the
number three group
the number three group should look like
it should look a little bit
so this is our number three group let me
draw it a little bit more like this
so number three group is behind us
number
three
and then finally you have your number
four group in yellow
your number four group which is just a
hydrogen and that's coming straight out
so that is coming straight out of well
not straight out but at an angle out of
the page so that's our number four group
i'll just label it number four it really
is just a hydrogen so i really didn't
have to simplify it much there now by
the rs system or by the con in gold
prelog system we want our number four
group to be behind to be the one
furthest back so we really want it kind
of where the number three position is
and so the easiest way i can think of
doing that is you can imagine this is
kind of a tripod that's leaning kind of
upside down or another way to view it as
you can kind of view it as an umbrella
with this is this is the the handle of
the umbrella and that's kind of the top
of the umbrella you know that would
block the rain i guess but the easiest
way to get the number four
carb or the number four group that's
actually a hydrogen in the number three
position would be to rotate it
you could imagine rotate it around the
axis defined by the number one group so
the number one group is just going to
stay where it is the number four is
going to rotate to the number three
group number three is going to rotate
around to the number two group and then
the number two group is going to rotate
to the number four where the number four
group is right now so if we were to
redraw that let's redraw our chiral
carbon
so let me scroll over a little bit
so we have our chiral carbon i put a
little asterisk there to say that that's
our chiral carbon the number four group
is now behind i'll do it with the
circles it makes it look a little bit
more like atoms so the number four group
is now behind where the number three
group used to be so number four
is now there
number four
number one hasn't changed that's kind of
the axis that we we rotated around so
the number one group has not changed
number one is still there
number two is now where number four used
to be
so number two is now jutting out of the
page
so number two
is now jutting out of the page
number two is now jutting out of the
page and then we have number three is
now where number two was
so number three is there
number three
and now that we've put our fourth group
behind the molecule we literally just
figure out whether we have to go
clockwise or counterclockwise to go from
one two to three and that's pretty
straightforward to go from one to two to
three we have to go
counter-clockwise
we have to go counter-clockwise counter
counterclockwise
or another way to think of it we're
going to the left
counterclockwise at least on the top of
the clock we're going to the left and so
since we're going to the left this is s
or sinister this is
s which is stands for sinister which is
latin for left so we're done we've named
it using the rs system this is
this molecule is s s sinister one bromo
three fluoro two three dimethyl butane